Betty Page was arguably the most popular
supermodel of the 20th century and she
would go down in history as the queen of
pinup even if you haven't heard of her
yet once you know who she is
you will begin to see her influence
practically everywhere you go if you
live in the United States the image is
inspired by her still show up in music
videos movies and pop culture to this
very day even if you recognize her face
very few people know the story of her
real life this woman never used her
circumstances as an excuse for failure
then the amount of grip she needed to
overcome obstacles to achieve her dreams
is absolutely astounding this is the
inspirational true story of Betty Page
[Music]
Betty May Paige was born on April the
22nd 1923 in Nashville Tennessee she was
the second of six children and the
oldest daughter of Roy and Edna Paige
her father was an auto mechanic that he
was also an alcoholic and he had trouble
holding down a job her mother was a
housewife and those six kids kept her
extremely busy during the Great
Depression Roy moved the family around
from place to place because he could
never keep a job
he was inflicting all forms of abuse on
his wife and daughters and he often
cheated on Edna as well when Betty was
10 years old her mother finally found
the strength to get a divorce
Edna Paige now had to work full-time
even though a few of her kids were still
dressed toddlers and babies since she
did not have much education she could
only find very low-paying jobs as the
oldest daughter all of the usual
domestic responsibilities fell on Betty
she was still only 10 but became the
surrogate mother to her younger siblings
by cooking cleaning and babysitting she
did all of this cheerfully and always
had a smile on her face indeed their
house became very popular because after
school that neighborhood kids could come
over to the house and play together
without any adult supervision
Betty loved watching movies and they
were her escape from her harsh reality
they inspired her to sing and dance in
the backyard on a makeshift stage that
the kids made out of discarded scraps of
wood since this was during the Great
Depression the kids did not have many
toys to play with this they were
entertained by Betty's imagination since
she had an audience who had eagerly
await to see what she did next she was
always pushing the envelope and thinking
about her next performance but those
dreams they would come to a screeching
halt
even with Betty's help six children was
far too much responsibility for Edna to
manage alone even though she worked
full-time the amount of money she made
was simply not enough Roy was not
sending her any form of child support
and they simply never heard from him
again
it got so bad that Edna had to choose
between starvation and giving up some of
her children to an orphanage Betty and
her younger sister were together in an
all-girls home and she encouraged her
sister to pretends that they were
characters in a movie by playing pretend
it helps her and her sisters stay strong
and resilient through this rather
traumatic experience
[Music]
after a few years Betty's mother had
saved up enough money and was able to
get custody of her children again Betty
was a few years old now and she had
grown into a beautiful young woman Edna
was concerned that Betty might make the
same mistake she did and give up her
future by marrying the first guy who
came along so she made a rule that Betty
was not allowed to have a boyfriend but
like most teenagers Betty rebelled in
high school she fell for Billy Neal the
all-star quarterback from the rival high
school he was everything you'd imagine
of the stereotypical cool kid back then
he wore leather jackets he rode a
motorcycle to school and probably
skipped class to smoke cigarettes but
that's just speculation
Betty fell in love we believe that the
years spent in the orphanage they were
more than enough for her to know that
she never wanted to depend on a man for
her financial security as her mother had
done she wanted to get a college
education so that she could always
support herself if she needed to keep in
mind now that in 1940 over 50% of the US
population dropped out of school after
the eighth grade very few women went on
to get a high school diploma and even
fewer went on to attempt a college
degree if they did they usually came
from well-to-do families in the upper
class but Betty wasn't going to let
family history stop her after school
that he joins the debate team and school
theatrical productions she studied
extremely hard and graduated second in
her class this allowed her to win a full
academic scholarship to Peabody's
Teachers College this was also the
moment that she got married to Billy
Mille even though she still dreamed of
being a Hollywood starlet Billy wanted
them to have a life together in
Nashville she loved him so much that she
didn't want to break up with him just to
pursue her dream the next best thing was
to become a teacher since she would be
able to do public speaking and share her
knowledge with younger kids so after
getting a bachelor's degree that he
started teaching at her old high school
her former principal and teachers
remembered how she excelled in academics
but she was still in her early 20s and
lost all that far off from the age of
her students she was so beautiful that
she became a target of harassment by the
young boys the male students thought
that with her perfect hourglass curves
she was simply too distracting to be
their teacher no matter how intelligent
she was on the inside
anyone could see past what she looked
like on the outside
apparently no one could take a female
teacher seriously unless she looks like
Professor McGonagall her husband Billy
Neal joins the army ins they stationed
him at a military base in San Francisco
before sending in overseas as his wife
Betty quit her job as a teacher and was
very excited about the move to
California she took this opportunity to
switch career paths and got a new job as
a secretary one of the men who visited
her office said that she was pretty
enough to be in the movies and he
offered to help her get an audition in
Los Angeles Betty it was excited hoping
that this would be the big break that
would make her the movie star that
should always dreamed of being Betty
showed up for a screen test by 20th
Century Fox but she hated the experience
she was poked and prodded by the makeup
hair and costume Department to the
points where she didn't even recognize
herself when she looked in the mirror
they told her that if she wanted to make
it she would have to change a lot of
things about herself like going blonde
and doing a makeup in a different way
the man who helped her get the screen
test made a move on her promising her
fame and fortune in exchange for
sleeping with him but Betty turned down
his advances the man threatened to ruin
her reputation and promised that he
would make sure that no one ever hired
her in Hollywood still she chose to stay
faithful to her husband she walked away
but Betty Page she wasn't alone today we
know that the likes of Harvey Weinstein
and Bill Cosby made it a habit of
preying on young actresses and that this
was happening to women for decades
before as well even though she had been
completely faithful to Billy he was
actually angry to come home and find out
that she was pursuing her acting career
while he was gone he wanted her to be
satisfied with just being a housewife
and he wanted to move back to Tennessee
she realized that there are missions in
life they were completely different and
they were just simply not compatible any
longer and with that they decided to get
a divorce
[Music]
in 1947 at 24 years old Betty moved to
New York City and began auditioning for
plays movies and commercials
unfortunately she ran into the same
problems that she had in Los Angeles men
in charge wanted more than just their
talents in exchange for her work and she
refused to change a moral compass for
three years she worked as a secretary in
Manhattan as the years slipped by she
was now considered to be too old to
start a career in show business she had
given up everything in order to be an
actress and soon enough it would be too
late
one day Betty was walking along the
beach on Coney Island's when she noticed
a man doing push-ups on the beach this
was a police officer named Jerry Tibbs
he said that he was a professional
photographer on the side and asked if
she would be interested in being paid to
be a model fame after talking to him for
a while longer she decided to say yes
when Tibbs asked how old she was she
pretended to be in her early 20s even
though by now she was already a 27 year
old divorcee nowadays this line about
being a photographer who is inviting a
young woman into his basement for
pictures is used by a surprisingly large
number of serial killers and of course
perverts but thankfully for her the
photography sessions went just as Tim
said they would and she was paid
handsomely for her time many of her
photos began showing up in girly
magazines around Harlem given minds that
this was after World War two where
photos of pin-up girls had become
incredibly popular a lot of young women
wanted to do their part to help the
troops and even after the war posing
provocatively for pinup it became a goal
of aspiring models so Betty Page was
excited to be part of this and she had
had such a good experience with Jerry
Tibbs that he invited her to become a
part of a Camera Club in the 1950s a
camera Club was where a studio would
bring in a group of models and both
amateur and professional photographers
would pay a fee to come and take
pictures of beautiful women sometimes
men would show up with a camera that was
empty simply because they wanted an
excuse to ogle beautiful women wearing
lingerie up close and personal but Betty
Page wasn't just good at modeling she
was a genius she needed very little
direction from the photographers and
knew how to strike a pose her face was
always cheerful looking friendly and
approachable there was something about
her that made men feel that she was the
girl next door
many of the cameramen words often
stopped taking pictures of the other
girls and
then more time on her because she was
just that good at her job
soon enough Bettie Page was raking in
money and she made far more than she
ever had as a secretary she saw this as
a stepping stone to finally make it into
the movies now today it's totally normal
for the likes of Victoria Secret Angels
to be on a strict diet and exercise
regimen every single day to keep
themselves fit but but back then models
usually showed up to have photos taken
of their natural body Bettie Page though
she didn't rely on a natural beauty to
get the job done
she worked out every day watched her
diet and even sewed new costumes that
would look good on camera she treated it
all very much like a business and
everything she did during her career was
the new standard for models would be
expected to do in the future
she began receiving requests to do photo
shoots all over New York City and
eventually she became the millionaire
whatever tastes changed photographers
expected Bettie Page to do things that
were more and more risque she would
agree to do it does any previous
hesitations that she had in the past
she knew that times were changing and if
she wanted to keep her career and
business going she would have to begin
posing in the nude if you think of
willingness to pose nude sounds sort of
contradictory when you consider the fact
that she refused to sleep with anyone to
get the job she had this to say being in
the nude isn't a disgrace unless you're
being promiscuous about it after all
when God created Adam and Eve they were
stark naked and in the Garden of Eden
God was probably naked as a jaybird too
so she continued to pose naked so long
as she thought that it was at least
tasteful one day the Camera Club decided
to find a secluded area in upstate New
York to have a nude photo shoot outside
where the models were frolicking in the
grass it shouldn't be a surprise to you
that the police showed up and arrested
the women and the photographers they
charged the men with disturbing the
peace and the women with indecent
exposure but he actually yelled at the
police officers saying that she refused
to accept that charge because she was
not an indecent person she demanded to
have the same charge as the men and they
finally gave in changing it to
disturbing the peace despite having to
serve time in jail for her nude photos
she still continued to do these photo
shoots anyway during the peak of her
popularity Bettie Page became Miss
January in 1955 in Playboy magazine Hugh
Hefner once said that he slept with 11
out of 12 of the cover models of each
playboy issue and Betty Page would have
been
exception who didn't have to sleep with
him in exchange for being published he
actually purchased a nude photos from a
female photographer and fellow model
named bunny Jaeger have not respected
Paige immensely saying that she was a
remarkable lady an iconic figure in pop
culture who influenced sexuality taste
in fashion someone who had a tremendous
impact on our society when the issue of
Playboy came out we can only imagine how
her former high school students mister
felt when they opens up the pages of
Playboy ins figured out that the teacher
they once had a crush on had now done a
full spread of nudes in glossy prints
for some that was probably a dream come
true
[Music]
modeling was paying the bills but Betty
Page still wanted to move in the
direction of being in the movies sibling
business partners Paula and Irving Klaw
and the movie star news store where they
sold beauty photography of pinup models
they also filmed short clips of Betty
dancing in lingerie and sold them to
customers she eventually starred in two
movies called stripper AMA and varieties
after work Betty was taking acting
classes and auditioning for plays on
Broadway but without much luck in 1955 a
senator named s desk of alpha created a
subcommittee that was cracking down on
comic books
pornography and basically anything else
that could be considered sinful the FBI
detained Betty Page and interrogated her
asking if Irving and Paula Klaw were
shooting pornographic movies at the
movie star new store
Betty protested saying that the women
were never fully nude in these movies
and there were never any men in them
either that his boss Irving Klaw was
taken to court before the Senate
subcommittee even though he was found
not guilty the mere suggestion that she
was starring in porn ruined about his
reputation her name it was printed in
newspapers all over New York City
Betty Page became the target of
slut-shaming and men were yelling at her
in the streets a stalker began to send
her letters threatening to kill her
since she had gotten to know the FBI
agents in New York City she contacted
them right away they believed that the
person who sent the letters was a known
serial killer they set up a plan where
they used Betty as bait to catch the
murderer and only jumped in at the last
minute to save her it turns out that the
stalker was only a 16 year old boy but
all of this took a serious toll on
Betty's meant
health and it was all downhill from
there in 1957 the Irving's had to shut
down the movie star News Store and Betty
Page was out of a job she decided to
stop working as a model and give up her
dream of becoming an actress she moved
to Florida and became a born-again
Christian the church made her feel like
she was a sinner and that she needed to
repent while in Florida she began to
attend Bible College and tried to become
a Christian missionary overseas in the
1960s however when they found out that
she was a divorcee they rejected her
saying that she was too indecent to
represent the church she began taking
graduate courses to earn a master's
degree in the hopes that maybe she could
go back to being a teacher but her
reputation it followed her there too and
she dropped out all along her mental
state continued to decline and by the
1970s she was beginning to suffer from
schizophrenia she had a nervous
breakdown and ended up in a mental
hospital after receiving psychiatric
treatment for several years she was
released during that time she had to be
essentially d programs because the
church had brainwashed her into hating
herself and all of our accomplishments
as time went on there was a revival in
interest of a Bettie Page she had been
one of the most photographed models of
the 20th century and when she retired
she seemingly disappeared without
explanation people wanted to know what
had happened to her and the mystery it
only added to the excitement for 40
years no one had heard anything about
her life after modeling in 1998 Playboy
magazine tracked her down and asked for
an interview they asked her if she ever
felt ashamed of her work while she was
doing it or if those feelings of guilt
came after she started receiving
criticism she said I never thought it
was shameful I felt normal it's just
that it was much better than pounding a
typewriter 8 hours a day which gets
monotonous for the rest of her life fans
sent Bettie Page letters telling her how
much they loved and appreciated her
bravery for paving the way for so many
other women and she finally got the
recognition and love that she deserved
she died of a heart attack in 2008 at 85
years old
at the time of her death she had a net
worth of 20 million dollars
even though it was considered to be very
scandalous at the time that sort of
modeling Bettie Page did is on par with
Victoria's Secret in the Calvin Klein
ads of today near nudity has become such
a big part of American culture that some
young women even put similar photos of
themselves on Instagram without a second
thought
today we're barely bat an eyelid that
those images of Bettie Page that were
deemed to be so sinful and inappropriate
one thing is for certain though without
her things wouldn't be the same Bettie
Page is like chronicler Corsa became the
inspiration for a number of fictional
characters including Jenny Blake from a
comic book called The Rocketeer she also
inspired the looks of celebrities like
Katy Perry Madonna and the modern-day
burlesque dancer Dita Von Teese in
modern times most men have moved on to
having crushes on other female
celebrities and the photos of Bettie
Page may not seem like anything special
today she is actually now more popular
with women especially feminists she was
strong smart independent and never
backed down on what she believed was
right even if it took her years of
heartache and struggle she was able to
make it in the modeling industry on her
own terms even after her death her
estate continues to make tons of money
in 2017 alone Bettie Page merchandise
sold for seven million dollars her
memory will continue to live on as one
of the most iconic women in all of
history so I really hope you found that
video interesting if you did please do
give us a thumbs up below don't forget
to subscribe brand new videos just like
this every day of the week if you're
looking for something else to watch
right now though I've got another
channel it's called top 10s we do
interesting top 10 lists you can find
that link to below as well as on the
screen now and as always thank you for
watching
you